das Fragenlotto erinnerst du dich noch
dran ich erinnere mich dunkel dran ja
ich nehme mal rosa das haben wir da
haben wir ein wunderbares Video draus
gemacht das haben wir betitelt ich glaub
nee das war nicht Wutausbruch was haben
wir noch gacht irgendwie
so Fanta 4 streitvlaufen der Kamera oder
so und das ist natürlich super gelaufen
ja weil euch e so superelt ihr
diskutiert darüber Trennung was ist los
was was war das noch ihr diskutiert
darüber über geblitzer ne andy ist ne W
einer von euch war geblitzt worden weiß
es nicht mehr es war s zum Schreien
komisch ja wir können streiten können
wir gut ich muss auch mal ein bisschen
was Filmen h so soll ich ja genau das
ist eine Frage an dich die roten sind
die bösen Fragen habe ich noch gar nicht
gesagt die Grünen sind harmlose Fragen
okay fang direkt mal mit einer bösen
Frage an zu viel WoW gespielt also World
of Warcraft oder warum sieht man das
warum sieht das Cover von Lektionen dem
11.0 so aus wie es aussieht ja mein das
hatich nichts mit diesem Videospiel zu
tun sondern es ist praktisch eine
Entwicklung die reflektorfalke
durchgemacht hat 10 Jahre später es ist
vielleicht das gleiche Bild aber er ist
älter geworden die Welt im Hintergrund
hat sich verändert im Original war es
eher eine klassische Comiczeichnung und
jetzt ist es eben auch ein Stil der das
jetzt wiederspiegelt diese krasse
Dreidimensionalität dieses fast
Porzellan ja greifbare so wird
heutzutage das ist
moderne
comikunst under ist unglaublich viel zu
erkennen das ist der Wahnsinn so so das
habe ich nicht geglaubt als ich das
gesehen habe der Sascha schickt mir
nachts irgendwann dieses Ding ich wollte
gerade ins Bett gehen und kriegt das auf
mein Bildschirm und sitzt 10 Minuten
lang
so se jetzt sehe ich das nur oder hat
der das auch schon gesehen ich meine hat
das da reingemacht was ich sehe ich
meine ich sehe was drin
ist und ich habe mit ih gesprochen er
hat tatsächlich es ist Absicht ein
großer Künstler hat mich auch
beruhigt
okay Dach mal next question
ja was gibst sie immer so jetzt nehme
ich mal eine freundliche neim mal eine
freundliche die sind aber auch schwierig
zu beantworten Gott sei
dankamt nett sind wobei manchmal sind
sie auch langweilig aber das sind halt
so fragen die Fans ein stellen würde z.B
Thomas Thomas was ich schon immer mal
fragen wollte warum sind die anderen
nicht so toll wie
du eine wirklich freundliche Frage kann
halt nicht jeder so toll sein wie nein
die anderen sind auch toll ja und
natürlich sind sie nicht so toll wie ich
aber sind in anderen Bereichen sogar
toller nein ja muss man sagen aber du
bist auch toll ach wie gehst du damit um
toll zu
sein es ist schon richtig dass ich
tatsächlich obwohl ich ja immer Versuch
oder wil ich eigentlich mich nicht jetzt
besser fühle als andere fühle ich mich
schon gut weil ich sehr viel Zuspruch
Krieg das tut schon das ist natürlich
eine unglaubliche Energie die die da
ständig kommt und damit das gefällt mir
kann ich nicht anders sagen das ist geil
klar aber hält mir nicht davon ab zu
sagen ihr seid auch geil jeder von euch
so geil wie ich kommt drauf an was man
draf draus macht
yeah nemer noch eine rote komm diese
bauchpinseleinen der Künstler das ist ja
ja aber das ist trotzdem ist du wirst
diese Frage nie geantwortet du hast nie
die Chance zu sagen es ist auch schön
toll zu seinm du wirst nicht gefragt und
das ist hier werden die Fragen weil
jeder
Moderator s ich
redaktionsung geil ja ich frag den warum
es so toll ist was kannst du nicht
machen
überhaupt
als medienmensch kann man ja den
Künstler gar nicht toll finden da wird
du ja deine Kritik verlieren ja gut das
stimmt ja du musst dich ja immer
distanziert Verhalten gegen deshalb
finde ich das auch so wahnsinnig
schwierig wenn Leute über Musik
berichten weil sie das nicht nicht ich
habe noch nie eine Kritik gelesen wo
einer gesagt hat Alter das neue Album
ist so geil das ist der Hammer die
Erleuchtung endlich hat er es gemacht
nach 7 Jahren wieder neues Album immer
alle so ja 7 Jahre sind vergangen die
Band hat sich entwickelt aber die Fans
werden vielleicht entäuscht sein gehst
Du anderen mit deinem gut menschtum
nicht tierisch auf die Nerven das ist
jetzt sehr lustig könnte auch sagen
gehst du mit deinem Vegetarismus anderen
nicht tierisch auf die
Nerven geht das denn egal
ähm ja Vegetarier gehen anderen auf die
Nerven ja aber tierisch K kann ein
Vegetarier ja versteh oh Gott Schlauch
gestand okay egal tut mir leid wenn ich
dir auf die Nerven gehe schalt ab gut
okay pass auf noch grüne zum absl das
Schöne an der Musik ist wirklich man
muss sie zwingt dich nicht zuzuhören und
du verlierst auch nichts wenn du sie
nicht hörst wenn du jetzt z.B Politiker
nicht
zuhörst musst trotzdem irgendwann wählen
gehen bei Musik kannst du abschalten
stört niemand kannst 10 Jahre später
wieder anmachen und sagen Bo jetzt jetzt
verstehe ich was der meinte also
insofern hoffe ich nerv nicht so sehr
mit dem gut Mensch tun aber bin halt
echt nicht der Bad Boy i'm
not du bist Idealist im besten Sinn guck
wie schaffst du es so positiv zu bleiben
das geht nur wenn wir Leute mit ihren
roten Fragen nicht tierisch auf den Sack
gehen nein nur Spaß nein aber das war ja
auch das Thema was wir im im Interview
hatten wie kann man bei wenn man wenn
man da wirklich du siehst ja Dinge und
du hältst sie dir du siehst sie nicht
nur du hältst sie dir vor Augen und
hältst dir anderen vor die Augen was ja
ein andlers war in schwere Depression zu
wäre in schwere Depression zu verfallen
aber du machst es nicht nee denk aber
darüber nach öfters ob es nicht Meer
Zeit wä jetzt wahnsinnig depressiv zu
werden wä gute Zeit gerade finde ich
obwohl nee bringt auch nichts bringt ja
auch nichts was soll denn das es ist äh
schwer zu sagen wie ich schaff so
positiv zu bleiben du hast gesagt beim
Tod deines Vaters hat sich noch was
verändert ja ja genau was war das ja das
Leben ist kostbar und schneller vorbei
als man denkt we der war krank aber der
ist innerhalb von ein paar Tagen war der
plötzlich tot ich war dabei das ist
ähm das Leben ist leiden auch keine
Frage das sagen ja die Buddhisten ne
aber das ganze Spektrum der Gefühle dass
wir haben dürfen ist es wert das das
Leben geht auch nicht ohne das also h eh
keine Wahl auch das Negative ja und auch
das ist wie wir ja auch wissen später
oft etwas was dich weitergebracht hat wo
du Entscheidung getroffen hast in deinem
Leben wo du auch mal Nein sagst zu etwas
wo du dich entscheidest da nicht
hinzugehen nicht weiter dort zu sein und
zu bleiben und das ist schon
alles innerhalb dieser ganzen Schmerzen
und dem ganzen was wir alles mitmachen
müssen jeden Tag trotzdem steht da
drüber das Leben ist geil sorry aber
sonst ohne das könnten wir das auch
alles gar nicht erlebeni manchmal denke
ich mit dem man erlebt so also das
Negative bleibt einem stärker hängen und
mit dem Alter hat man doch so viel
traurige Dinge erlebt also die auch
wirklich traurig waren dass da schon
eine grundtrauer kommt die man früher
nicht hatte ja da stimme ich Dir zu es
gibt auch diesen Film crumpy old man von
dem smuto dann erzählt hat wo so alte
Leute also in Anführungzeichen alte
Leute so dann so über die Welt abkotzen
weil die Hal so im Lauf ihres Lebens und
das werden die meisten
verbittern ja und da darf man nie
vergessen dass das was du erlebt hast
hast nur du erlebt du kannst es nicht
auf die Welt beziehen du kannst nicht
sagen das ist scheiße weil es ich
scheiße fand wenn du es am nächsten Tag
in der nächsten Woche irgendwann später
erlebst ist es vielleicht gar nicht mehr
Scheiße vielleicht ist dann hilfreich
also man muss vorsichtig sein mit diesen
Generalisierungen und sie kommen weil du
immer mehr Erfahrung hast und die
Erfahrung doktriniert dir oder weiß gar
nicht ob was ist das von Wort
doktriniert SAS obtruiert obuiert woll
du sagen das ist schön das nehme
ich dass das so ist das Leben ist so
auch genau das wollte ich sagen und du
denkst
weißt du ich bin so oft enttäuscht
worden in der Liebe Liebe ist scheiße
nein es stimmt nicht es ist nicht so und
gleichze natürlich ist es so liebe ist
scheiße Liebe ist geil Liebe ist Schmerz
Liebe ist Erleuchtung du hast eben diese
Welt hat alles ständig und du fischt dir
raus was du definierst als Realität aber
das ist sie nicht die ist alles insofern
schöpfen wir aus dem Pool und hoffen
dass es
geil bleibt vielleicht verbittern
verbittere ich auch irgendwann kotzt
mich alle an aber dann würde ich abhauen
raus hier weg von euch dann muss ich
euch nicht mit meiner schlechten Laune K
gehen ich dachte ja Neuseeland aber
jetzt wiror aber ist ein bisschen
schwierig geworden in letzter Zeit
trotzdem glaube ich noch ein wirkliches
Paradies
aber werden sehen was passiert
gut